this from the daily wire says parents of
students attending columbia grammar and
preparatory school in manhattan were
furious after the school forced students
to take an explicit class on pornography
without parental consent of course the
school at first denied hosting the
workshop then later apologized
the class which involved the slideshow
and a lecture by an instructor
featured raunchy images and
presentations on porn genres and only
fans
a subscription website used largely for
pornography the new york post detailed
the workshop
let's see how much of this i can
actually read
the often explicit slide presentation
and lecture by
the person's name is fonte justine
ang fonte is the lecturer
the presidential lecture by fonte to the
120 boys and girls included lessons on
how porn takes care of
three big male vulnerability
vulnerabilities
statistics on the orgasm gap showing
straight women have far fewer orgasms
with their partners than gay men or
women
and photos of partially nude women
summon bondage
bondage to analyze what is porn and what
is art
fonte's presentation some of which was
seen by the post included a list of the
most searched pornographic terms of 2019
including and now there are a bunch of
things that i know i can't read on the
air
one slide cited various porn genres
such as incest themed consensual
barely legal and kink and bdsm
the workshop was designed and taught by
justine fonte
the health director at dalton another
top prep school
and by the way i looked up her bio um
and her bio says that she's
on twitter anyway says she's a
passionate she they health educator
fighting for a more sex-positive world
so that's what's happening at that
school i mean this is this is a slightly
more grotesque and explicit version
of the kind of sex ed that you find in
schools all across the country so
you might say well yeah this is some
fancy school in new york a bunch of far
left
wackos are there mostly far left wackos
sending their kids there
of course this is happening there it's
not happening in my kids school they
would never do that
uh i wouldn't be so sure this is
again slightly more explicit than
if if your kid is 16 years old and is in
a public school
they've probably had a lesson similar to
this
maybe slightly more toned down
but that's what that's what sex ed is
that's the whole point
that's the whole point of sex ed in
school now
what they call uh comprehensive sex
education
that's the term of art for it so if your
kid's been through a quote-unquote
comprehensive sex education course
they've been through stuff like this
which is why i have always said that
and this should have been our argument
all along it should have been
uh let's reform sex ed or let's make
sure there's parental consent before or
any of that
our argument all along should have been
this shouldn't none of this should be in
be taught in school at all yes there
should be no
sex ed in school at all nothing called
sex ed
we want to teach about human
reproduction
great that's for science we want to talk
about the
the the body parts and how they function
fantastic
well there's there are classes for that
anatomy you know that's anatomy that's
biology
so i'm not saying that the school should
overlook the scientific facts of human
reproduction
entirely no although we're getting to a
point now where i don't trust the school
to teach those subjects either because
who knows what they're telling kids
about how do you determine a male from a
female and that kind of thing
but in an ideal scenario yeah obviously
you're going to teach that stuff in
school because these are scientific
facts
but there is no reason why the school
should go
beyond that at all we don't need to get
into any of uh
you know your trying to shape
how kids view sexuality
giving them advice on
how to engage in it when to engage in it
none of that
your own your own per as a teacher your
own personal moral and ethical views on
these subjects
none of that should be in the school
it's not the place for it
that should have been our message all
along on the right but but it wasn't and
so now you end up
with this kind of thing and the other
thing you have to keep in mind is that
you know the schools believe
that they have total control over
your kids and that they are more you
know that
that their moral claim to your children
supersedes your own because they're the
educators
and you're sending your kid to them for
six or seven hours a day
and so they really believe most of the
people running these schools
across the country they really believe
that as a parent it's it's actually none
of your business
what's happening at school
if your kid comes out as transgender at
school
and all the teachers know it it's none
of your business they don't have to tell
you that
that's that's the attitude and um
so when you send your kid into school
that's what you're encountering
that's what they're encountering i
should say well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content